merci georges cette convention concerne
la sécurité et nous y avons apporté des
réponses et nous allons y apporter
nicolas sarkozy dans son discours de
clôture
vas y apporter des réponses très
précises très concret très pragmatique
mais pour moi la sécurité bien sûr
relève de l'organisation des forces de
police des forces de renseignement mais
aujourd'hui j'ai la conviction voire la
certitude que nous progresserons dans
notre pays pour reconquérir cette
liberté qu'est la sécurité en améliorant
d'abord notre système judiciaire
en améliorant le fonctionnement de la
justice en faisant en sorte que la
politique pénale retrouve un sens et
c'est le sens de cette peine de la peine
que tu évoqué georges il faut qu'on
réhabilite qu on réinstalle au coeur de
notre fonctionnement démocratique des
mots qui sont devenus avec madame
taubira des mots tabous
le mot peine le mot sanction le mot
autorités ces mots et bien doivent
réinvestir le discours public et pas
simplement le discours doivent
réinvestir nos politiques alors oui il
faut que la peine retrouve un sens il
faut que ces peines ne soit plus
systématiquement déconstruite parce que
d'abord c'est un scandale démocratique
lorsqu'une personne est condamnée elle
l'est par un tribunal qui juge ne
l'oublions jamais au nom du peuple
souverain
au nom du peuple français est ce qu'à
fait un tribunal est bien seul un
tribunal devrait pouvoir le défaire
aujourd'hui c'est fait dans l'anonymat
d'un cabinet du juge d'application des
peines dans un bureau d'exécution des
peines
une personne est condamnée dans une
salle de tribunal correctionnel elle
sort et en catimini elle passe dans le
bureau d'exécution des peines ou dans
celui du et sa peine et déconstruite
c'est un scandale démocratique
il faut que l'on redonne du sens à la
peine une peine aussi courte soit elle
aussi courte soit elle doit être exécuté
elle ne doit plus être automatiquement
aménagé comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
donc je veux insister là dessus sur la
nécessité de redonner un sens dissuasif
à la peine
c'est la peine et son application
certaines qui sera le meilleur moyen de
prévention contre la récidive
ce ne sont pas des mesures éducatives
bien sûr qu'il en faut bien sûr qu'il
faut que ce soit un outil dans un panel
complet mais ayons la certitude que le
meilleur moyen de lutter contre la
récidive
c'est de faire en sorte que ce n est qu
une personne qui a été condamné une fois
et bien lorsqu'elle aura été condamné la
deuxième fois voit sa peine alourdie
comme nous l'avions fait avec les peines
plancher qui ont été abolies par madame
taubira et le gouvernement actuel alors
oui un des enjeux essentiels pour
retrouver cette liberté qu'est la
sécurité dans notre pays c'est de
redonner du sens à la peine aujourd'hui
est de faire en sorte que toutes les
décisions de justice soient exécutés
alors nous avons donné des réponses plus
de peines de prison
la suppression de cet aménagement
systématique au delà de six mois de
prison ferme
oui c'est tout cela que nous devons
mettre en oeuvre pour faire en sorte que
dans notre pays la sanction retrouve
toute sa force dissuasive